la pression aura finalement eu raison de
Hockey Canada
[Musique]
la lumière sur comment hacker Canada
gère les processus de plainte il y a une
longue semaine à faire des gens tiennent
vraiment quand quelqu'un là-bas soit
vraiment fait des valeurs canadiennes
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines vont être déterminants sur
l'avenir et la confiance qu'on peut
avoir dans Hockey Canada version 2.0 la
fédération de hockey de l'Ontario
qualifie ce moment d'extrêmement
important elle juge que la confiance
doit être reconstruite avec les
Canadiens sur et hors de la glace en
Québec estime qu'il est essentiel que
les futurs administrateurs posent des
gestes concrets pour effectuer des
changements en profondeur en termes de
respect d'intégrité et de culture
l'ancien joueur de hockey et activiste
Charden Kennedy ne se réjouit pas pour
le moment
c'est des missions ne régleront pas le
problème de culture toxique selon lui il
faut un engagement dit-il de la part de
la haute direction qui doit croire au
changement et en faire la promotion
c'est des missions suffiront-elles pour
ramener les commanditaires Tim Hortons
par exemple croient qu'il s'agit d'un
premier pas dans la bonne direction pour
regagner la confiance des Canadiens mais
l'entreprise ne reconsidérera pas
rétablir son soutien financier à Hockey
Canada tant que l'organisation n'aura
pas démontré qu'elle peut faire preuve
de leadership ici Valérie Michaela
Ottawa